lio pennywise octobre je suis né à malte
portugal mais tu as vécu au mozambique
ou non oui pendant 14 mois ces souvenirs
de sa faute
à l'époque le mozambique était une
colonie portugaise
ton père charmant de vasconcelos était
militaire là-bas
et puis ta mère joue en a eu marre delà
de la brousse elle l'a laissé
elle est rentrée au portugal pourtant
tarder comme ça elle en a pas eu marre
de la bourse était vraiment un climat
difficile c'était la guerre des colonies
se passer des choses vraiment affreuse
au mozambique en angola on torturait
c'était vraiment du fascisme c'était
sous salazar et ma mère était marié à
cet homme qu'elle aimait et c'est vrai
que ça se passait pas bien pour ce cours
elle ne la bat parce qu'elle voyait des
choses qui la révolte et humainement
terriblement et lui il était sergent
dans l'armée y participaient donc ça +
puis se fait que ce soit effectivement
un macho mais qui n'est pas match au
portugal c'est vraiment dur à trouver
alors ensuite elle est revenue au
portugal elle a rencontré un homme qui
s'appelle berthod qui était un soulier
du qu'il voulait pas faire la guerre des
colonies manas en partie l arrêté ses
études
oui elle est partie en belgique et quand
est arrivé en belgique c'était très dur
pour elle ça a été dur pour elle et pour
alberto beaucoup fêté ça a été dur pour
moi aussi mais je pense plus durs pour
beaucoup plus dur pour mon beaucoup
protégé que si l'on fait au début quand
ils sont arrivés là bas pour vivre un
tous les métiers que font les immigrants
d'être plongeurs femme de ménage
serveuse nice ait et diot pendant
effectivement pendant deux ans on a vécu
dans la clandestinité mais c'est quoi le
pire souvenir de cette époque là le pire
souvenir de cette époque c'était que ma
mère travailler la nuit et que je ne
supportait pas d'être séparé d'elle et
donc je mens je m'enfuis y ait de chez
moi pour aller la retrouver à son
restaurant c'était facile parce que les
toilettes étaient à l'entresol du bas
rhin je disais je vais aller faire pipi
j'allume ma chance je prenais mon
manteau et zouk je filais je pourrais
dans toutes les rues et puis je me
mettais à la porte du restaurant et puis
ma mère servait de l'autre côté
et de temps en temps je la voyais faire
les mêmes chercher permettent à une
table by pr minutes après l'ouverture
arrivions courant relatifs à rusal excès
en eau
ben voila je jouer aux cow-boys et aux
indiens système c'est que la vie c'est
un peu la valise en carton
non pas du tout